we're here boom we made it we made it so
you voiced a prisoner in Guardians one
check out the new
that's true you were supposed to play
Wonder Man well I was Simon Williams in
two I appeared in movie posters in a
scene that was that didn't actually wind
up in the movie so do you feel like this
is your MCU debut or where do we count
it yes let's let's call this the debut
of my MCU actual appearance actual
appearance how does that feel really
good you're talking to a guy I used to
we used to go down we used to take we
used to have a comic book rack my
brother and I shared a comic book record
we spent a week in my room and then a
week in his room let's go back and forth
tons of comics on there and once in a
while we pull them all out took a big
pile of comics down to the we book Inn
on White Avenue and Edmonton Alberta and
we trade them in for a smaller pile of
secondhand comics and my dad would buy
us the rest of the pile of secondhand
comics and we come back and put them all
back the thing and then we lived in
Commons
to be a part of this never mind to
actually just be witness to the idea
that this is all from the pages now
coming to what looks like to us real
life seeing it come to life it's better
than I could have dreamed it
but to be a participant David Osmond
uses this term it's like it you're in
nerdvana because you've been like so
many amazing characters that you
probably grew up reading and you're like
oh I got to play this I got a voiceless
I got to do this yeah putting your
finger in all sorts of little pies that
you were tasting as a child yes
absolutely absolutely so this suit this
character is wearing this suit I hope
it's a suit it's a suit right it's a
well it's a it's a skin suit organically
grown cybernetic armor perhaps we could
maybe yes cybernetic Army okay okay how
was that what did that feel like
when you first lay eyes on it it's
disturbing it looks somewhat like a
lobster was made out of keloid scars and
tried to be disguised as a Bread Basket
in a fancy restaurant that's what you're
looking at yes it's a pile on the floor
or hanging on a hanger and then you
start to put this thing on it's it's
legs it's boots it's a it's a top that
you can you could have grown into foot
it's like a reverse molting for a crab
you're gonna go in through the back lock
it in and then there's like a diaper
wraps around the butt cheeks and the
piece and the everything that's pulled
and held
it's a lot it's a lot
but you can't complain because your
audience that you're complaining to is
Karen Gillen and so I Saldana and de
Batista who just spent seven hours in
prosthetic makeup and body painting and
they're going to spend several hours
more getting it off before they come
back and do it tomorrow all over again
so you can't complain you really can't
sure but
but suit and I'm gonna hang you from the
ceiling and swing around
I checked off a lot of boxes on things I
want to do on TV you're like I'm in
uh you've worked for James multiple
times how do you describe working with
him how is it unique to other directors
you've worked with well everybody has
their own personal style of course uh
you know I've nurtured a lot of
relationships over the years James is a
fella I've held very near and dear to my
art he's remained one of my close
friends uh there's reasons for that I
enjoy his company I get along with him I
like a sense of humor I like
How concerned he is about people about
his projects about his work he's he
cares about what he does
as a director as a writer director
he's super good at his job he absolutely
loves telling stories I'm super picky
when it comes to my entertainment and
the stories that I watch and he
satisfies me he scratches all the itches
I really love his stuff so being able to
participate
it's a wonderful experience because
you're hanging out with your friend
you're doing all the things that
professionally you want to do as far as
storytelling and then on top of it
um you can't help it it rubs off on you
you get credit for his incredible work
because he puts your face on it he goes
now go do this go do exactly what I tell
you to do the people say you're amazing
for doing what James told you to do
that's my experience with James yeah I
mean this Trilogy is so emotionally
satisfying and incredible who knew a
ragtag group of aliens with
um Space Opera Stakes that have nothing
to do with we can't relate to them in
any way how does he take that
and make us
care so much I cried four times at the
premiere four times yeah I'm an
emotional guy one of those times I was
speaking
but three minutes is pretty good
yeah it's like I'm crying over a tree
voiced by Vin Diesel like what is
happening
but here we are this character is a
raccoon it's like laughing at a we're
crying at a puppet doing the scene you
know it's it's it's this is Art this is
Art and they're making me care I if I
can go to a movie and walk away having
felt something I feel that's my movie
ticket money will spend and what he's
really good at too is those needle drops
I'm curious what your favorite song
across the Guardians Trilogy has been
there is oh across the trilogy there was
a an incredible scene that required some
incredible music and they uh threw in
some Beastie Boys Beastie Boys uh to me
uh
it's much like Def Leppard in that
back in the 80s when 90s when everybody
was listening to them I missed that boat
but now I hear that and it Harkens me
back to a time that I felt the simpler
or better whatever time I was with
filtering out the ground so it
I I'm a late coming fan but but it it
brings me back it really transports me
and it has value to me in that transport
it really inspires you you can feel
inspiration Welling you can feel
something welling up within you music
has that ability it does and I think
James uses that as a tool very concisely
what is your getting ready song
I uh I'm a big fan of uh Road to Nowhere
there's a couple of Ed Sheeran songs I
don't mind so much to get ready to uh I
will go with um
CCR Down in the corner okay I like that
nice and plucky
the emotionalness of this movie
James is your friend we didn't know
volume 3 was ever gonna happen so that
moment where he goes hey we're doing
this we're finishing this Trilogy as
intended what was that like for you and
him being like and you're going to be a
part of it it's bittersweet again so I'm
a fan I am a fan I didn't enjoy this
comic book I am really
some might say overly attached to this
film Trilogy I care about these
characters he's made me care
he's picked some really wonderful
talented people to uh to convey these
messages but I'm I'm a sucker I'm I'm
right there I'm I am buying everything
that they are selling
to be a part of it
if you watch people making a movie and
you say oh I bet they're having fun
you're right they're probably having
actually three times more fun than you
think like at the after part like if you
guys didn't like each other you wouldn't
all be hanging out all night until they
were like you guys gotta go
those nights are amazing it's like the
night before the Oscars because we get
to celebrate this incredible product
that so many people have come together
to make uh it's like we've all been
nominated and when it goes out into the
public that's what we find out who's who
the Winner's gonna be yeah but this is
like the night before the Oscars
everyone's a winner it's a lot to
celebrate it was a very intense evening
[Music]